it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games and new releases
and this week battlefield is releasing
hardline with force out to prove that
it's a shooter to be remembered it's
going back to classic cops and robbers
storylines but with intense action
sequences and explosions that will make
you feel like you're in die hard hard
line comes with seven modes and nine
maps future expansions the first of
which is called criminal activity
launches this summer and it will
introduce even more maps to the shooter
the explosions begin on the 17th this
week you face the wrath of handsome Jax
hologram with the second episode of
tales from the borderlands Atlas mugged
but unlike the hologram of Tupac Jack's
not here to entertain you following the
events of the first episode you play
recent Fiona trying to get the big score
expect to run into other memorable
characters like mad moxxi and vault
hunter zero the second of five episodes
debuts on the 17th
square-enix give some love to an old
classic with the HD remaster of final
fantasy type-0 just like when you played
the first time you'll have to be on your
game when you take down some of those
seriously dastardly villains I'll talk
about you cactuar start using blog a
bombs on the 17th a few games that might
have slipped under the radar coming out
on current-gen this week wolf the Red
Hood Diaries makes it side-scrolling
debut as you play a heavily corseted
hood out for revenge against the person
who killed her father I bet it was the
wolf also we get bladestorm nightmare
One Hundred Years War get your history
books out because this game is loosely
based on the real hundred years war
between kingdoms of England and France
in the fourteenth and fifteenth
centuries both games drop on the 17th
get some popcorn and invite your friends
over because Mario Party 10 is being
released on Wii U this week prepare to
destroy friends and loved ones in the
ultimate battle to prove whoever has the
most stars is objectively smarter and
more good looking we're all here to have
a good time just don't you take my star
it's all in good fun that drops on the
20th speaking of episodic adventures
resident evil revelations ends its
series with the final installment this
week episode 4 this should bring
together the stories of very Burton
looking for his daughter and some other
characters and finally offer answers to
the mysteries of this infected Island
story concludes starting on the 17 it's
the final episode
for further details visit gamespot.com
release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week